i have a buddy staying with me today um
this week actually he's staying with me
and my wife
um here in nashville and man we got to
talking on my front porch last night
about election stuff and the
economy and voting and all of the things
and things and things
and i felt my blood pressure going up i
started talking too much and talking too
much and i'm sure
all of the internet apps are recording
all of my conversations i'm having with
my friend on my front porch
and i was just getting more like and i
thought
dude stop every every day you go out to
talk to people
on the radio you talk to people in
person and tell them to chill out
control what they can control right
anxiety is just an alarm system
well here's the deal anxiety is an alarm
system
it's goes off when you're scared it goes
off when you're disconnected it goes off
when you can't control the future
and that's where we all are right now in
a couple of weeks we're gonna vote i
don't know when this show is going to go
out but
when you hear it it'll be right up
against voting time
and voting makes us feel small elections
make us feel small
because here's why when we control the
things we can control
we realize that we just have one thing
that we can do
it's like going to the circus and you're
throwing ping pong balls into those fish
bowls and you're trying to get that
little goldfish
and when we're voting we get one
ping-pong toss that's it
and november 7th is going to come and go
and there's nothing we can do to change
the date
there's nothing we can do to change the
outcome other than cast our one vote and
here's the deal
you have to vote you have to
i don't want i don't care you have to
it's a part of being a citizen it's a
part of
of participation it's a part of taking
ownership in
your day your kids day your life your
future
i continue to be moved by memories of
pictures tv shots of countries
throughout my lifetime who have gone
from
various political regimes to democracies
however flimsy and
hard and wobbly those democracies are
but seeing the lines
down the blocks of people who finally
have an opportunity to be heard
to talk and it's just a big deal
you got to participate right so if
you're feeling anxious if you're feeling
nervous
here's a couple of things you can do
to deal with the election anxiety number
one make a decision you're gonna vote i
just made it with you
we're all gonna go vote number one uh
our number two
limit your media intake by now you know
you know who you're voting for period
you are not thinking i don't know maybe
uh maybe uh
ah man voting day is november 3rd james
child's in there not november 7th it's
november 3rd um so yeah voting down
november 3rd
you guys got that but here's the deal
you already know you're going to vote
for
you know there's nobody in america right
now going i don't know
you know so that means you don't have to
keep watching
that means you can turn off your your
any of your devices
i love this term uh doom scrolling where
you're just going there looking for
things that are going to make you
anxious to get you that
that cortisol hit right um to get you
that
anxious feeling that hurt your heart
rate up a little bit if you need your
heart rate up go have some coffee
go have some coffee but just turn it off
you know who you're gonna vote for
um decide locally
if you wanna get some more information
if you want to learn about some things
you can do locally in your area which by
the way is where you have the most
impact
ask about your local candidates read up
on them read about them
talk to people um in your community
about them
that's where you're gonna you know maybe
have some ideas i didn't know about this
judge i didn't know about this
representative
but think about things you can do
locally and then create a plan for how
you're gonna get involved one of the
things i'm gonna do in my house is i'm
gonna take my son with me when i go vote
and that might mean i've got to get him
out of school depending on when i can
get out of here but i want him to see
the lines
i want him to sit in that line and he's
ten it's gonna be painful for all of us
all the people in my community is gonna
be painful for by what i want him to
have memories seared into his
mitochondria
that his dad stood in a long long line
because this was a big deal i want him
to remember how important this moment is
and then make time to rest and play to
laugh to be with your community to kick
a soccer ball around
to otherwise be a human being that's
what you can control
you get one vote you get one ping pong
ball into the fishbowl and that's it
do what you can do and put the rest down
mindlessly scrolling
who won this we all saw the debate we
saw who won right
we saw who won no one right so we all
let's just move on let's let's do our
vote let's
learn about what's going on locally
let's be with one another as human
beings let's
wave at crosswalks and let's try to
regain our humanity in the next
few weeks and then whoever wins we're
still gonna
pump gas next to one another we're still
gonna share meals next to one another in
restaurants we're still gonna
wave to each other at crosswalks let's
regain our humanity and let's not go on
the offensive let's not go on the curl
up in a ball let's move forward together
united is one group of people trying to
do the best we can